[Musique]
merci merci de m'avoir laissé être c'est
le sujet de ce soir la liberté d'être
moi j'ai pu être moi sont mes peurs sont
mes croyances mais vous qu'est ce qui
s'est passé quand vous avez présenté
votre mental vous avez senti légaux le
petit bonhomme là dedans qui disaient
'oh mon dieu la pauvre elle a pas
préparé son texte ou d'autres en colère
quand même mais c'est qu'ils sont côte à
bien par faire installer dic c'est être
préparé
vous l'avez senti cette petite voix
oui c'est didier rigot l'enfant non il
m'a préparé vous avez santé de petit
bout en bout
on l'a tous on peut l'appeler jugement
positif ou négatif
ils sont pas toujours négatif les
jugements mais elle est là toujours et
aujourd'hui ce que j'aimerais vous
parler c'est de les purement
personnelles on a beaucoup parlé de
développement personnel apprenons à nous
les purs et moi je pouvais venir tout nu
sur la scène vous parler de ça mais
didier maniement et coûte 1 metz ça se
fait pas trop
peut-être qu'on subisse bon alors j'ai
dit il faut que je trouve une autre
manière pour vous faire ressentir ça ce
moment de silence particulier j'aimerais
que vous vous connectez à vous à ce
qu'il ya à l'intérieur de vous bien sûr
je vais vous parler un peu de mon
histoire pour faire des similitudes mais
c'est vous qui m'intéressait ce soir et
j'ai choisi une artiste on voit pas son
petit graffitis qui est en bas qui
s'appelle suzy et je lui ai demandé un
dessin épuré cette partie c'est une
femme formidable
elle a une couleur unique et je vais
vous dire une chose
vous avez tous une couleur unique et
c'est celle ci qu'il faut protéger ces
six qu'il ne faut pas laisser polluer
par les autres donc c'est ce petit
bonhomme là vous vous souvenez quand
vous arrivez enfin qu'est school y est
la joyau bon il ya ceux qui pleurent qui
crie on connaît tout ça aussi mais cette
joie l'envi l'énergie la joie toujours
il court partout et on arrive dans ce
monde et pourquoi il faut s'habiller
pour faire son armoire mais tes habits
et que je vais maintenant si je mets ça
on va voir truc moi ça va pas les labit
on passe mais il ya aussi le masque que
vous devez mettre tous les jours ce que
je mets le masque de la mère de famille
bonne famille puisque je mêle main
de là profilers est ce que je mets le
masque du coach je ne sais pas c'est
l'hypnotise à sion c'est quand on a
commencé à faire ce premier pas sur la
rivière parce que ce petit bonhomme
ce n'est pas seulement ma vie c'est la
vôtre mais aussi ce qu'on va faire ce
soir ensemble traversée chaque pierre
pour retrouver notre couleur l'essentiel
l'essentiel la liberté d'être donc on
arrive dans un moment où on est en fait
dans l'ignorance
on ne sait pas du tout qu'on est en
train de se mettre des masques etc ont
fait faux au contraire on réussit on est
plusieurs témoins aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
dit que c'était la réussite comme kevin
mais il a compris il s'est mis en
rupture non tu as eu une rupture pas
forcément choisi la rupture pour changer
pour ceux qui se masquent ne me convient
peut il être serré et j'ai envie de
l'enlever d'accord donc on a tous un
moment comme ça dans la vie on est dans
l'ignorance ma vie c'était je voulais
être inspectrice à l'appel de sûreté
j'avais 8 ans j'ai dit je vais d'idées
makhoul sawaya mes parents ont essayé
professeurs non on va essayer oui mais
peut-être non je vais dîner mac os alors
j'ai fait quoi j'ai fait ce que tout le
monde demande de faire les écoles qu'il
faut le sport qu'il faut apprendre les
langues qu'il faut je suis devenue
inspectrice
j'ai rencontré mon mari et je fais des
enfants mais je masse me serrait mais
alors facile c'était de la faute des
autres
mon chef comprenez rien mon mari mais
mes peurs comme il fallait qu chambre
quand même mes enfants faisait que de
pleurer j'aurais dû avoir des maisons
font beaucoup plus facile à vivre
bref donc est ce que je fais un peu
comme kevin allemand je shoote tout le
monde je recommence je mets renens vos
masques je m'étais toujours pas trouvé
j'ai pas dis je m'étais encore tourner
mais on doit cette époque là je vous dis
là c'est trop je ne mettais toujours pas
trouvé alors j'ai recommencé j'ai mis
des autres masques j'ai fait aux études
j'ai retrouvé un autre mari j'ai fait
des nouveaux enfants avec qui sont
toujours là cela parce que j'ai compris
deux trois petits trucs au milieu mais
j'étais toujours pas heureuse il ya des
gens qui ont une chance je vais vous
dire c'est une chance inès c'est une
chose que tu partages et dans la vie
d'être si jeune que toi et d'avoir
compris d'avoir compris ta couleur ta
beauté d'être moi j'ai pas eu cette
chance
leur rupture j'ai dû créer une rupture
alors j'ai choisi une rupture un peu
peut-être pour les français bizarre ou
un peu qu'on ne peut pas comprendre mais
j'ai décidé de me mettre en répliquant
j'ai dit comment je peux faire ça parce
qu'il fallait que je parte de cette
hypnotise à sion vous avez où tout le
monde dit qu'on doit être donc j'ai un
mari italien qui me met bien dans un
cadre des enfants une famille faut que
je parte de chez moi comment je vais
faire pour partir de chez moi je veux
être en rupture
je me suis dit koh lanta pas mal koh
lanta pour tout de suite
nos besoins 2012 va se faire je vous ai
donc koh lanta pour moi c'était pas les
médias nous ayons vous m'avez pas
tellement vu un an les médias c'était
vraiment me dire aujourd'hui gm lettre
je veux retrouver qui je suis comment je
vais faire pour aller dans un jeu
d'aventuré où je vais devoir choisir de
nouveau un masque ce forcément il ya un
masque à m qu'est ce que je vais y
apprendre est-ce que je vais être
capable de résister aux éléments et
surtout aux autres et alors dans ce jeu
d'aventuré vous connaissez koh lanta non
non il y en a qui connaissent pas pour
nous mais sur une île déserte pendant 40
jours on doit résister on est deux
équipes broadband tv guide
on est exclu si on a mal fait il ya
beaucoup de jeux de stratégie ce n'était
pas ça qui m'intéressait ce qui
m'intéressait c'était l'humain demierre
est ce que je vais trouver le potentiel
chez quelqu'un est ce que je vais
trouver potentiel chez moi parce que je
vais me rencontrer et alors sur tout ce
que j'ai appris à koh lanta c'est que
lego il est présent et vous l'avez vu
dans le jeu c'est souvent les égouts qui
gagne au niveau de la stratégie mais
l'ego et vous fait perdre et je vais
vous montrer dans ce petit jeu c'est
deux minutes vidéo vous allez entendre
denis brogniart qui expliquent le jeu et
après je vous explique ce que j'ai
appris
c'est de l'amour pour sa santé et tu vas
toucher la première promo qui va
passionner la stratégie des jaunes et
malines rapprocher une pierre pour
faciliter le travail de gégé qui ne
s'est pas bien nager
les rouges et les jaunes 3,2 à chaque
aventurier doit aller récupérer une
pierre de son choix et il a rapporté
dans le cercle correspondant à son
équipe
mais le retour ne peut se faire qu'en
d'apnée benoît s'arrête au niveau des
premières pierres alors que laurent rona
piste veut tenter de rapporter une des
pierres les plus éloignés et laisser
celles qui sont les plus proches du pour
ton au moins vingt nageurs de son équipe
[Musique]
il faut les chemins d'accès des partis
car 064 bien partout les deux équipes
sont au coude à coude
[Musique]
l'équipe des jaunes avantage aux jeux
c'est au tour de gégé de s'élancer et
ses coéquipiers ont oublié de lui
rapproché une pierre pour l'aider le
doyen va devoir au moins touchés vouer
et revenir s'il ne peut pas disqualifier
son métier
ça y est gégé a touché la bouée mais ils
paniquent ils n'arrivent plus du tout
avancé chez j'ai fait du surplace
il ne parvient pas à rejoindre le ponton
à la nage mois à peine 15 ans de
repartir il faut que j'y ai passé le
témoin alors qu'est ce qu'on a vu
continuez vous a vu que c'était très
clair au départ les jaunes ont eu la
stratégie de mettre un caillou à côté du
cercle
vous avez vu une hémiplégie il n'y avait
pas de courant mais il savait pas nager
donc on avait bien décidé tous le
premier devait ramener la part amener le
deuxième devait ramener à côté du sert
qui ne l'a pas ramené et moi je pars
j'avais la stratégie de nantes est même
initiatrice du truc
on va nager un autre truc je me
rappellerai toujours et j'en rêve la
nuit je vous promets de genève la nuit
parce que je me suis dit je ramène la
dernière pierre et d'un cercle
vous avez déjà mis la paire dans le
cercle
parce que là j'ai fait perdre l'équipe
pas que moi mais j'aurais dû la mettre à
côté du cercle
s'il n'avait pas été un délai court mais
bien dans l'être je leur ai mis à côté
du cercle et toute l'histoire de koh
lanta aurait joué donc oui légaux dans
le sport dans certains jeux vous permet
d'aller plus loin
mais à la fin celui qui vous fait
résister et qui vous rend fier de vous
c'est bien votre être donc je trouve que
cet exemple étaient très impressionnants
et de ce jour là je me suis dit tu vois
carreau chaque fois que tu es dans lego
tu te trompes
sait-on être qu'il faut pousser et comme
on a parlé tatouages moi aussi j'en ai
un essai écrit m je n'ai pas écrit pour
que vous puissiez lire mais pour que je
me souvienne qu'il faut rester dans
l'être donc suite à koh lanta et bien je
suis revenu à ma famille
l'idée d'une grandiose je me suis dit
non non ça n'a pas de la faute des
autres
c'est de la tienne j'ai compris une
chose lorsque tu n'attends plus rien d
autre tu attends tout de toi est arrivé
dans ma famille je vous dis j'ai
commencé à trouver cette petite clé
comment me libérer de mes chaînes il ya
des premiers pas à faire je vous ai
parlé du champ gauche le chemin gosset
cette petite voix que vous avez dans
votre tête quand vous m'avez regardes et
tu dois il faut au moins dieu vous
l'entendez les fois il aurait fallu n'en
fait pas comme ça alors alexandre
jollien qui est un philosophe dit ces
radios fm jeunesse est d'accord avec
vous je vous dis pas qu'il faut tuer le
le chemin go quand je l'appelle il faut
l'apprivoiser et certaines fois il faut
le laisser sortir de sa cage un tronc
vous allez aller nulle part un peu tous
être un gourou en haut d'une montagne
s'est pas l'idée mais laissez-le galoper
quand vous en avez besoin
quand vous n'avez plus besoin le mettez
le dans la cage est laissée sortir votre
couleur ce sera tellement plus
intéressant de revenir à qui vous êtes
vraiment donc je ne vous dis pas
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai fait ce dernier pas
mais mon chien go nage dans l'eau
tranquille - hull tourne autour de moi
comme sur cette image et j'ai jeté la
plupart de mes croyances
vous savez une rose quand elle pousse
elle se fait des épines c'est normal de
créer des épines pour se protéger du
monde
mais avant l'intelligence de regarder
lesquels nous sont encore utiles ou pas
c'est bien les premiers pas vers la
liberté de foi vous êtes d'accord
donc aujourd'hui je suis revenu à mes
premiers amours
je suis devenu profilers lie to me a
servi faites attention si quelqu'un dans
la salle je le saurai instantanément ça
n'est pas vrai mais existe pas un seul
signe du mensonge
mais pour devenir un bon profilers il
faut avant tout arrêter de croire qu'on
a raison arrêtez de penser que je sais
tout désordre
donc mon plus grand challenge
aujourd'hui et de mais purée de poser
mes croyances de poser tous mes filtres
pour être capable d'identifier l'autre
et quand vous dites c'est anti quand
vous identifier l'autre tel qu'il est
vous recevez sa couleur particulière est
unique au monde
comme un cadeau merveilleux et soudain
vous vous rendez compte que vous devenez
performant et que vous devenez peut-être
un expert dans votre métier
alors pour finir cette petite parenthèse
parce que je n'avais pas envie de vous
dire ce qu'il faut faire
j'aimerais tellement pour vous connecter
à qui vous êtes à l'intérieur on va
peut-être finir sur un silence où je
vais vous accompagne avec quelques mots
pour que vous vous reconnecter à vous à
ce qu'il ya au fond de vous d'accord et
souvenez vous ne cherchez pas être soyez
vous même tous les autres sont déjà pris
respire et on finit sur silence respirer
tranquillement dans mon début quand je
vous ai regardé tous les ans tu essaies
père riba ce moment présente fabuleux
d'être tous ensemble et surtout
rendez-moi service ne pensez pas à la
liberté de retraite
[Applaudissements]